hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
August 28
2022 what's going on Now 23 sorry 2023.
oh [__] you know some days you're having
such a great day that something [__]
up has to happen and that's what
happened to me today I had some buddies
of mine
um a buddy of mine was placed drums
you know he's in town he's out in
Riverside he goes you got to come out
check out my new kit and blah blah blah
so I go down there I watch him play
sound check
sick ass Ludwig kid double bass my dub
it's amazing it lets me sit on the kid
for a second we go out we get coffee
lead singer hangs out everything's
[__] great I'm not naming names
because I don't know I don't I just you
know
I was like [__] name-dropping and
[__] but totally cool guys right so we
[__] we're hanging out
and uh I'm driving home
and I'm just merging on to this highway
driving like you know [__] 10 15
miles an hour
and all of a sudden boom I just get
rear-ended and look there's like this
[__] 18 wheeler it's like there's no
way you didn't see me I didn't whip into
his Lane I wasn't being that you know
the truckers hate when the cars like
don't respect him and cut them off and
like I wasn't even doing that I was just
gradually going in
he just [__] bangs into the back of
my car just keeps going
so I'm like what the [__] I'm looking at
him and he gives me like the peace sign
like
like you know peace means everything
like peace I'm sorry it peace out
I'm out of here so I think he meant I'm
out of here so I got his license plate
so I call the [__] 9-1-1
they're like do you know kind of like
what exit it happened on and you gotta
pull over I gotta send the cop I go I
don't have time I'm I'm leaving the
country and they go well you can go to a
CHP thing you do this you file a report
do you have his license like I got his
license plate when you [__] do this
he did it I just said all right all
right forget it
forget it just forget it
I'm not pulling over the side of the
road there's no [__] place to pull
over I'm not going to get hit while I'm
sitting here
and at the end of the [__] day
I'm going on the road for two weeks I
don't know what my car looks like I
ended up getting on my car it's not bad
he [__] up the rap he scratched some
[__] but just you know what annoyed me
is that he didn't pull over if he just
pulled over and gave me his side I would
just be like all right you know
I don't want to go through all this
[__] do you [__] it I don't care all
right
I never put anything through my
insurance company I never do it I never
do it because even if it's not my fault
they still raise my rate so [__] them
okay and I don't want to talk to a bunch
of cops about this [__] they're busy
doing other stuff and then I got to give
out all this [__] information you
know I don't want to get the guy that
drove the truck in trouble
his version maybe I did something wrong
I just
was coming over
so
whatever I got a body shop
I'm just gonna drop it off tomorrow
and when I return from my run of dates
overseas it will be repaired they'll say
how much it is I will pay it and I will
get off my [__] life
um
whatever it was that guy driving the
truck really [__] annoyed me because
I was gonna be cool because if he said
it was my fault and it sounded like it
was I didn't think it was I don't give a
[__]
you know but whatever I get it
I get it he probably deals with guys in
cars all the time that are [__]
[__] and he had had enough and just
decided he was gonna [__] drive into
me and I hit the lottery right but also
I look at it like the balance of life
you know
my day was [__] great
you know and I went down I got to play a
[__] killer double bass drum set
have coffee and just watch this amazing
band play soundcheck and it's just like
why wouldn't that happen
[Applause]
it just bugged me that he didn't even
[__] you I'm not pulling over [__] you
I don't know
sometimes I really feel like uh
the rude Behavior
of the internet is now spilling out
into real life and I just really mean
like
the level of rude that people are and
like comments and [__] like that
um
that just becomes like a habit and just
everybody just has to be like a douche
you know
I mean I thought I was being cool
because like I could have been like oh
my God my neck oh my I have Whiplash oh
my God I'm gonna sue your [__]
company and I wasn't being that guy
I don't know what what what what the
[__] you gonna do what are you gonna do
what the [__] ing I do so anyway
um
I'm getting ready to go to Abu Dhabi Abu
Dhabi Abu Dhabi Abu dhabido
um
I'm not a lady I'm nervous about the
[__] Shelf
because
they asked me to do it and then I said
really and they were like yeah and I was
like all right
and then it becomes like don't talk
about this don't talk about that I'm
like dude what the [__]
now I'm all nervous
I ain't trying to get arrested abroad
I'll go out there in a [__] tuxedo
and do knock-knock jokes I I am not
yeah
I don't need any [__] Lenny Bruce
cred I'm not trying to get arrested and
[__] I'm not doing that [__] so
whatever I'm gonna feel them out I think
it's going to be like a bunch of expats
from what I heard
English Australia American you know
Bankers developers whatever I think that
that's what the crowd's gonna be so
I'm gonna get the lay of the land before
I go up there but you know
um
there's always like that uh
that thing in the back of my head
like I remember when I did that gig in
India that I had such a great time doing
but there was like I had to get a piece
of paper saying
I could go into the country to do it and
then I had to get that piece of paper
that said I could leave and I couldn't
get it until I went to the country and I
had to go to whatever the hell it was
the consulate the embassy I don't know
what it was but I just remember the
promoter was like ah don't worry man I I
go in there with you we'll go in and
we'll knock it out and we went to go
into the place and then they were like
yeah no you can't come in only the
comedian and then I [__] went in
there
and I'm just sitting there like
it out you know and there was some
beautiful songwriter that won a Grammy
and she went over there and they didn't
let her out so I'm thinking like if they
don't let her out there's no [__] way
they're letting me out
unless it's based on looks like reverse
like get this ugly
[__] ball Ginger out of here maybe I
got a chance that way
um I don't know what but all I remember
was I was sitting in that place
with this nice lady I met from
Afghanistan and she was trying to figure
out if she was going to get out and then
it kind of hit me like wow man I
remember when I was a kid I saw that
movie Stripes
that guy was trying to teach him English
and he was like you know son of [__]
[__] son of [__] [__] I realized like
wow I am literally in the classroom
right now
because I don't speak
you know whatever what is the language
Hindu Indian I don't even know what the
language you know I I come from American
public schools so all they talked me
about was the [__] Mayflower it's
always about white guys coming over in
ships
that's all I know
so I finally got the [__] piece of
paper
and uh if you ever go to India the
people there are [__] hilarious
they're ball Breakers they've got an
unbelievable sense of humor that's what
that was my big takeaway
when I met the comedians over there like
like
you're gonna have a good time when you
go there man they're really really like
funny people
um so I said to the lady I was like all
right I got the piece of paper I go so
tonight after my show when I you know I
take the red eye out I can leave right
and
you know she did that thing where she
does like the bobble head thing which
that mean that's like shrugging your
shoulders over there she did not yes she
didn't say no she just did the bobble
head thing and then I was like well what
is what was the purpose of me getting
this then
and she did it again
and I was like all right well
I'm getting DMV Vibes here so I'm just
gonna take my piece of paper and leave
so
I went out and I did my show and the
entire time I'm doing the show in the
back of my head
I'm thinking like am I gonna get out of
here
um
whatever but I did my show and then
afterwards I hung out with
a bunch of comics from over there and we
had a great [__] time
and then I went to the airport and
fortunately I was it was so late at
night there was like nobody there
and I hand a piece of paper to the dude
I'm like yes this is saying I could
leave and he [__] does the bobble
head thing and I was like I lost my
temper
I remember that like I'm fine I have to
go I I'm you know I have a show I'm
gonna do you know I just did that and I
sort of gorillaed my once I lost my
temper I was like oh no I just [__]
myself but
it actually worked maybe he was tired or
what
and uh I did but I did not feel
comfortable until
I think we connected in Dubai I didn't
feel comfortable until
the plane took off
and we were over Europe and then I just
kept playing in my head like well I
still haven't cleared Customs to get
back into the United States
so anyway
I'm anticipating that it's going to be a
great show I just I'm a little like you
know
I just you know I don't want to go into
somebody's country and piss people off
like I'm not trying to do that I'm also
I don't feel like going over there
getting in trouble you know
so and I'm not gonna lie to you guys I
have so much [__] up [__] in my act
right now
um
and I'm just going through it in my head
and it's like you ever see when those
people come over
and they're just like you know they're
trying to help somebody like clean up
their closet
and what I love is all I do is just
throw out a bunch of [__] they don't try
to talk to the person and figure out how
the [__] did you end up with this closet
full of [__] they don't they just go
when's the last time you wear this uh
that's in that pile these we're keeping
these no I like those no we're throwing
these out that's what my actors right
now I'm just like can I do this bit no
no throw that one out can I do that
[__] throw that out so I think um
but I think this happens to me a lot
because I freaked out when I was doing
that gig in India going like you know
are they gonna know what I'm talking
about and blah blah blah
am I going to get out of the country and
everything worked out so I think that
that's what's gonna happen I'm just more
like uh I just want to get over there
and do it
uh because I'm hoping it goes well and
then I can come back and go to like a
Moto GP race or a Formula One race over
there or something like that
um
and then I'm also like I've never been
in like an Arabic country or anything
like that so I'm kind of fascinated
to just like
you know
do what I do in every country I just
kind of find like a cafe where it's like
good people watching and I just sit and
I just kind of watch people go by and I
you know see the interactions and the
cars like everything is just like
interesting you know
like I think the dumbest thing you can
do when you go to another country is to
go to like a tourist attraction unless
it was something you really wanted like
I get the Eiffel Tower and some [__]
like that but like
you know even if you go to Chicago like
don't [__] go to the top of the Sears
Tower
what looked down at a bunch of [__] you
should be doing
um
I wish there was like a sporting event
or something
uh because that's always fun I remember
when I went to uh
I was in England one time and I went to
a Premier League game
what the photo that was
Everton versus I don't know
Arsenal
I can't remember who the [__] it was
um but just being there
it's like I can't [__] believe I'm in
England right now and I'm at a [__]
out of respect for English people I'll
say football you know we call it soccer
I can't believe I'm at this [__]
thing
um watching people drinking pints and
ordering I could murder a cup of tea I
still remember this guy
I could murder my cup of tea and I was
just like this is [__] Wild
who knew who knew right signing up for
some stupid
Talent contest 30 years ago I would end
up I get to do this now it's [__]
wild so what am I going to do I'm gonna
cry about this [__]
um you know who knows maybe I was
[__] in the wrong maybe I drifted
into his Lane I didn't think I did
I didn't think I did but uh
I got out of my car I was expecting that
the tail light was going to be busted
and all of that [__] so it was way less
damage or whatever so but of course it's
the rear quarter and the bumper
you know it can never just be like the
bumper Roy we'll just take the bumper
out and [__] switch it in
everything's good
you'll be fine
you don't bug this [__] on other things
something that bugged the [__] out of me
was I was watching um
this clip of uh
it was Jason Bonham
and he was talking about his dad
and he was saying what was amazing is my
dad even when he got off his kit and he
got him you know Jason had like a little
kid he was saying
he sounded
he still sounded like him
even on his little kit so then and then
they cut to Ginger Baker
from uh Beware of Mr Baker and he's you
know that classic line where he's
trashing John Bonham
going John Bonham couldn't swing a sack
of [__]
and
I don't know
you know what
I don't [__] get that guy I don't get
Ginger Baker and what his [__]
problem was and what all that run in his
yet can somebody direct me
to this song because I know this cream
because I'm a fan of cream and I am a
fan of Ginger Baker but like the way he
[__] just
shits on people like he's the be-all
end-all
okay now I'm just whatever I'm a dad
drummer what the [__] do I know but like
that guy is nowhere near
the greatest rock drummer of all time
and he is certainly nowhere near the
greatest Jazz drummer of all time
he was definitely a great drummer but
what the f what the [__] was he like in
what world
does that guy challenge Elvin Jones to a
drum battle
there's some great quote from Elvin
Jones he was like laughing going like
yeah man that guy's like [__]
delusional
um
anyway
it just [__]
maybe it was the edit you know because I
like
like listening
to Jason telling like those family
stories about his dad man they're
[__] incredible and then this [__]
you know I don't want to go ginger on
Ginger here with the crime but this
[__] grumpy [__] like who gives a
[__] about you and your backwards beat
he put the snare on one and three oh
yeah it sounded like [__]
that background I'm sorry the backwards
beat
it doesn't sound good
I don't even think it grooves like I
don't like okay all right
yeah you did that why did you do the
while you did with that song is show me
why they usually have to snare on two
and four
almost [__] Ginger Baker fans it's
just backwards beat
I would take Keith Moon Over Ginger
Baker all right I'm deliberately trying
to ruffle some feathers here because I'm
trying to find out because even in that
documentary Eric Clapton who I love
when he was talking about Ginger versus
John Bonham even he was going oh this is
John was not even in the same [__]
like stratosphere as Ginger Baker
and like what am I not gonna listen to
Eric Clapton but like I don't know my
[__] regular ears I don't see what
the big deal is
dude
in the white room
I I don't hear it I'm not saying he
stinks
I'm not saying that at all but I'm just
saying like like the distance he tries
to put between himself and John Bonham
like I said I'm just a dad drummer I'm
just that guy that goes into Guitar
Center and tries to buy the same [__]
that my heroes played thinking that I'm
then gonna be as good as them I did that
for a good 30 years before I was like
why don't you just go buy a [__] drum
kit that feels comfortable to sit behind
you [__] idiot right
anyway sorry
maybe it's the whiplash
you know what's funny you know I get
Whiplash from is my kids
they just keep [__]
you know when I'm watching TV or looking
at my phone and they don't like it they
just grab my head and and as fast as
they can whip it around to where they
are
it's like a reverse chiropractor kid
chiropractor
um
anyway I haven't even looked at any of
the questions or anything what I'm
supposed to read this week I just
immediately went into talking
about what the [__] just happened
I just can't imagine like driving into
somebody and
like they just keep going
and it's like how come you can't call
the cops be like yeah this guy drove
into me and here's the license plate
like I learned that a long time ago back
on my Prius days
I was sitting in at this traffic light
and it was one of those things that
there was like I think two rows of
traffic probably about six cars deep
and this guy just came flying in like 35
miles an hour in like like he was
splitting wood went right between all of
us taking side view mirrors and door
handles with them
like
what the [__] like what just happened
I think he was having some road rage
thing with somebody else and he just
punched the gas
like I'm gonna win at all costs so
all the guys airbags go off and you
don't see them
and everybody's getting out of that car
was like dude what the [__]
like why did that person do that is that
person okay and finally the door opens
and the guy's got his bag and everything
with him and he just starts yelling at
all of us
and he leaves
and I'm thinking in my head I go that
guy's going to [__] jail
then I called A buddy of mine who's a
lawyer does he go to jail he's like well
does anybody really nah
it's like you can drive into six cars
and then just leave the scene and you
don't go to jail
it's just I don't know
there's so much [__] that I thought you
went to jail for you just evidently you
just you don't go to jail
um who knew who the [__] knew
let me see what some of the stuff you
guys did anybody write in
do's and don'ts thoughts for Bill's song
I hate oh we got one okay
another hated song so we do have a
couple of those all right well let me
get to the uh
the podcast reads here for the week
I just can't believe you can like have
an 18-wheeler drive into something they
look at you and you just give them the
[__] deuces
all right man well you know sucks to be
you
um
anyway
I was happy that it wasn't a lot of
damage and I at the end of the day maybe
the guy had a bad day I don't want to
get that on his [__] record so
whatever whatever maybe it was me who
gives a [__] who gives a [__]
what am I going to do now am I going to
carry this [__] and I'm gonna sit there
and like get angry about this guy I'm
not
all right I am lucky enough to do my
dream for a living
all right I have a beautiful wife two
beautiful kids and I'm gonna go around
I'm gonna go to
Abu Dhabi and then all of Europe telling
jokes it's a fender bender Bill who
gives a [__]
there we go sorry this is literally me
working it out the old me oh the old me
oh the old me oh geez oh oh oh oh I
would have been upset
all right policy genius
I didn't even get mad at the guy
I just hit the window down when I was on
and he had his window down I couldn't
hear I was just like why did you do that
I wasn't even mad I was like confused
why
is this like a movie shoot and you're
the Stunt Driver and you I don't know
anyway policy genius
you know if you have family like I do
you know how much loved ones depend on
you in the worst case scenario you
wouldn't want to worry about you
wouldn't want to worry about money
all right let me tell you from personal
experience it is super satisfying to
check life insurance off your to-do list
you know what they just wrote that for
me to say that because you're supposed
to say that but that actually is true
and I had that guy thing where I didn't
want to get life insurance because I
couldn't deal with my own mortality but
then after I did it and I knew that
everybody that I loved was going to be
taken care of
it made me feel great but I would say
get rid of the knives in your house
okay because you just
you know
you kind of
you dying now is like a good I'm not
selling it well
um and getting covered
could be even more sad more satisfying
when you use policy genius hey if you
love your wife and kids and you don't
want them to be destitute
um
just play a little life insurance right
get a little life insurance here with
policy genius you can find life
insurance policies uh that start at just
25 per month for one million dollars of
coverage some options offer coverage in
as little as a week and avoid and avoid
unnecessary medical exams uh they work
for you not the insurance they work for
you not the insurance companies that
means they don't have an incentive to
recommend one insurer over another
so you can trust their guidance policy
genius is for parents caregivers and
anyone else who has people who depend on
them they simply they simplify the
process of getting life insurance so you
can protect people you love no wonder
they have thousands of five star reviews
on Google and trustpilot your loved ones
deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to find and buy it
head to policygenius.com or click the
link in the description to get your free
uh life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save that's
policygenius.com
all right
is this lastly but not leastly oh it is
look at that not a lot of heavy lifting
all right let's see why won't you do
that there we go all right a g one
you know our next partner is ag1 the
daily foundational nutrition supplement
that supports whole body health
why why take a bunch of different things
when you can just mix one scoop of
powder in water once a day
uh ag-1 was designed with ease in mind
so you can live healthier and better
without having to complicate your
routine ag1 replaces your multivitamin
probiotic and More in one simple
drinkable habit ag1 is a foundational
nutrition supplement that delivers
comprehensive nutrients to support whole
body Health Science driven formulation
of vitamins probiotics and Whole Food
Source nutrients every scoop is packed
with 75 vitamins minerals and probiotics
and Whole Foods sourced ingredients of
high quality that gives you major
benefits like gut and mood support
boosted energy and even healthier
looking skin hair and nails
let's start adding a scoop of this to my
[__] Applejacks
ag1 is raising the standard for quality
in the supplement category ag1 helps you
build your health Foundation First if
you want to take ownership of your
health try ag1
and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free ag1 travel packs
with your first purchase go to
drinkag1.com that's drink
ag1.com
to check it out
shout out to Angel Salazar
um
all right
so there we go now let's get into the
reads here for this week everybody you
guys chime in this is where your voice
is heard
uh all right MSG hey Bill big fan and
discovered your podcast about a month
ago wow wasn't that wonderful I've never
subscribed to anything so quickly
well maybe I need to promote it a little
more
uh quick question for you I attended
your Newark show in June and I'm
wondering if I should attend your show
at Madison Square Garden will it be the
same stand-up hour or different content
uh yeah no dude if you went to Newark I
would stay home
I mean it my shows are always different
I do write all the time I do add new
things but the bones of it
is going to be uh would be the same
thing
um
I again go check out somebody else's
show you saw my hour
all right and then when the special
comes out whenever I take my next
special you'll see some of the different
things from the comfort of your own home
I don't want you to go into the Lincoln
Tunnel drive in and merge like a
gentleman and then get rear-ended by
some trucker who is sick of cars or
whatever the [__] he's sick of and then
he won't pull over because you're in the
tunnel
and then you gotta deal with New York
cops saying Ah that's actually on the
Jersey side of the [__] rigor romaro
yeah whatever
whatever
um
let's see when did I do the Newark thing
well I mean we'll be five months later
you know what I would say there's going
to be too much of the same stuff and I
don't want to rip you off
so I would stay home there there's that
all right New York dues and don'ts
hey there old Billy New York balls big
fan from Norway here
man I had such a good time any time I've
ever gone to Oslo and I still just
remembered like
how much people were drinking they got
after it and they but they were fun
they were fun drunks like the key to
those
three countries there
Norway Sweden and Finland is you want to
stay on the southern tip you don't want
to go north where the Sun never shines
and people are so into death metal that
they actually kill members of other
bands you don't need to do that you stay
down near
what is that body or what is that the
Baltic Sea
is that the Baltic Sea let's see if I
remember anything
why does this thing always do this
it goes right back to whatever the [__]
you have in your Google Maps all right
we're going around the world the world
the world that is the Baltic Sea
and what is this other thing it's sort
of oh the
skagarach
whatever the hell that is uh the North
Sea
that's [__] exciting
look at these now somebody told me that
people in the south of France
when all the jerk off tourists come
there they actually go
to Croatia there's some Lake that's
where they go
to get the [__]
away from all of us pasty people
invading their their world
so what is it is it the Black Sea that
they're on
um I don't know Bill can you stick with
the question all right what was I
talking about I don't know
uh oh we talk about this person from a
Norwegian person
I have a trip to New York soon and I was
wondering if you could give some advice
on what to do while vacationing there
well I moved away in 2007 so
um
I'll do the best I can my girlfriend and
I are going to spend nine days there
that's a good number I wouldn't go any
further I don't like being on vacation
any longer than like like nine days is
Kind of Perfect 10 days is too much 14
days you're like what do I even do for a
living anymore
um I have planned trips to several
comedy clubs but that's all I thought of
she is a freaking list that will leave
me sweating my ass off if we do all she
has planned all right let's talk about
that right there
okay one of the dumbest things you can
do
is go to a city
and just you know go on vacation to some
place and then just fill up every day
with [__] to do at that point you're not
on vacation anymore
okay like
um that's one of one of the many things
that I love about my wife is I remember
when we went oh my God we wanted to go
to Paris that's all we talked about
forever we wanted to go there since I
first met her and you know we weren't
able to do it until I think we went we
went there on uh on our honeymoon
we finally went
and at that point we had been talking
about it forever and we finally went
there and there was all of this [__]
that we wanted to go and see and
everything and we just sort of like
gravitated towards these cafes and we
just sort of sat
with the locals and just watched all the
tourists go by and all of that type of
[__] and like I just feel like
you should you gotta like it's you gotta
do some touristy [__]
but you can't do it like who wants to go
on vacation and just spend it standing
in line
with a bunch of jerk offs wearing
styrofoam Statue of Liberty helmets
or whatever that Ring of Honor that they
[__] whatever the hell it is that she
has
I do love how she welcomes your your
your poor giveness your your oppressed
you look at the look on her face she
doesn't seem excited
yeah
she's just kind of like hey all right
you know buckle up
are you guys the latest immigrants here
well you're going to get blamed for
everything good luck to you
um
this is this is how I would approach
your girlfriend I would just say listen
um give me your top like five things
that you want to do
and I
you know will definitely do those
but I don't think we use the pronium we
identify with we
I don't think we want to spend every day
running around getting on subways trying
to see all of this [__] New York is not
going anywhere
all right
let's
like oh my God what does she want to do
she wants to go up the Freedom Tower
and then [__] go up the Empire State
Building and then go see the Statue of
Liberty and then go to Roosevelt is it
Roosevelt Island what no that's not it
what's the one where everybody got
processed
Roosevelt Island is that [__] weirdo
island with the
gondola
Ellis Island
and then we got to go to Brooklyn
ah and we gotta go see Central like go
see Central Park
and just chill out
walk around
maybe go see where the John Lennon thing
is or maybe you don't
there's always some music there's some
band playing there just walk around
at a nice leisurely [__] pace
[__] all these restaurants oh my God we
have to eat there they have the you know
[__] all of that if you get there you
get there that should be your Vibe weed
is legal you know take five milligrams
walk around the city
there's a lot of [__] all you just need
to do is look at it you don't need to go
in there
you know
when I was in Paris you know I did the
Louvre
I was just like where is the Mona Lisa
and I got my stupid ticket I walked in I
looked at it it was literally the size
of an air conditioned filter air
conditioner filter like a house one
right it was that big it was a bunch of
[__] jerk offs standing there not
jerk off people that actually appreciate
art I was there because like I guess I
was supposed to look at it but I mean it
might as well have been a reprint
in a post office how quickly I went in
there and once again what I loved about
my wife I'm like okay we saw it you want
to get the [__] out of here she's like
yeah
let's go to a cafe
and let's let's go have some drinks
she smoked he was used to smoke
cigarettes right so she's smoking a
cigarette I had a little cigar going
you know
I got a [__] uh
whatever whatever the [__] I ordered it
was delicious food and that's what we
did and we would just sit there
and do that so I would try
um to do that when when you're in New
York there's a lot of [__] you can just
look at you don't need to go up the
Empire State Building all right
you want that experience just look out
your window when you're Landing yes
there is New York we see it from above
God damn there's a lot of buildings
fantastic
do not
Empire State building is all right
Statue of Liberty do not do that do not
[__] do that go to the southern tip
there Battery Park take a [__]
picture of it do not get on that [__]
boat
and go over there and stand in line to
climb up into a [__] statue all right
the windows are dirty and you what you
want to see is what's over her shoulder
the city you're just looking out
at you know over to Staten Island or
whatever it's biggest [__] waste of
time
all right I would skip Ellis Island
I wouldn't go up any [__] buildings
all right
um she's a woman so she's going to want
to go to a museum so do the Museum of
Natural History or whatever like that
but really just sort of find places
where there's young people and where
they're eating or where they're hanging
out and just go in there I don't know
what any of those places are but I would
do that but if you're gonna [__]
you know they have this is the muse the
history of taxi cabs in New York [__]
all of that [__]
go to a baseball game
go to a Yankee game
I think the U.S open is still going on
go see a tennis match or something like
that you get your sporting event in
[__] everything else
all right
we're gonna go down to Wall Street and
watch I am [__] ring the bell [__]
all of that you know what and and to get
her to hear your opinion
just
if compare them to
tourist attractions that you and your
girlfriend never go to in Oslo Oslo
however the [__] he's saying
the history of uh whaling whatever the
[__] you guys do over there what do you
guys do over there
whatever you do you keep it on the down
low so I I
respect it and let me finish reading
this thing so I come to you Mr Burr with
the hope that you can give some insight
on how we should spend our time I'd go
to a Yankee game
I find out where the best slices of
pizza are there's a couple of sick
places in Brooklyn there's a couple of
sick places in Manhattan but there's
only a couple the rest of them are
living off the reputation
all right
um okay great food he wants to know uh
[__] it's just been too [__] long
there's there's a bunch of
websites out there
every place is great
um if you want a really old school I do
like that catch's Diner
Deli or whatever
um and that is a good experience late at
night when there's a bunch of young
people all hammered going in there or
whatever drugs that they're on that's a
fun little part of New York
um
and the sandwiches are delicious they're
[__] incredible the gigantic
they're just and you only eat half of it
and the next morning you wake up and eat
the other half
and you actually enjoy the heartburn
um
other than that the whole [__] I
would do Central Park I would go to a
Yankee game
um
if the US opens I've already said
everything that I would do I don't know
anything else
but like everything else is on
um is online and I'll just give you some
advice here
all right if you're trying to pick a
coffee place
when you look up the top coffee places
to go to the pictures should only be of
coffee if it's pictures of coffee and
food [__] that place if the coffee is in
plastic containers [__] that place if
it's just coffee and they're in and each
one looks like it's in the the special
mug that that type of coffee should be
in that's what you want to gravitate
towards other than that it's New York
you're gonna have a great time
it's essentially
[Music]
um
our Paris it's the best city that we
have as far as
um
mix of people you know people come from
all over move there dominate
and
reach their goals and then New Yorkers
like sort of act like they're they did
they just start adopting people like the
same way their teams just sign free
agents they sort of sign free agent
talented people
oh
um anyway all right thoughts for Bill
hey Bill
hey there Billy red face
um what do they say here I am an 18 year
old fan been listening with my dad since
I was 14. Ah that's cool and I've gone
back to check out all your other stuff
uh you often you're often checking
yourself about sounding like an old man
if you complain about the way my
generation my generation and the ones
before me do stuff I don't understand
why or how it used to be but only a
small percent of my generation is
represented in the media yeah the worst
part
the worst part you're always you're
always
judged
by the worst of you you know I mean
that's the basis of racism and all of
that stuff
uh misogyny I'm raising my hand
um I don't judge all of women I just
judge the psychos
um all right movies and that's our
webinar all right movies and music
have you have you thinking that we're
all dancing for our phones and listening
exclusively to trap music reality is
that it makes it hard for kids my age to
find cool stuff even though it's
everywhere because most don't really
look
since much as it has shoved down our
throat I actually know what you mean
because back in the day a scene could
develop
and then it all of a sudden you know
people would start hearing about it and
would grow and it would grow and grow
and then when
um the mainstream found out about it
that would sort of be the end of it and
then you'd get some bands new style of
clothing
of food or whatever
um sort of like you know I always bring
this up like the metal scene in Los
Angeles the grunge scene
San Francisco and uh sorry Seattle then
there was a little scene in San
Francisco as far as I just know I just
know about white music right
um
but now like all of that [__]
it just gets devoured
before it even has a chance
to get going like let's say it was an
amazing book that I read was the Beastie
Boys or Beastie Boys not the Beastie but
Beastie Boys put out this book
and it described Manhattan
in the in the 80s like after like
um
it had almost gone bankrupt After the
Blackout after Son of Sam and all of
that and sort of the uh
when the crack 80s were happening and
there was all of this it was sort of
post I would say uh
was that that classic Club down there
cbgb's right sort of post that all those
bands Blondie to Talking Heads Ramones
all of them
had made it
and they were doing these gigs
it seemed like it was in the area of
like Tribeca whatever but it was like
wild it was just like there was just
nobody there and it just seemed like
their generation had the keys to this
city
um
and this amazing scene came out of that
um I wish there was like more of that
um but like everybody's like filming
everything and just ratting it out
before it even gets going so anyway
um
this kid says kids in my school just
listen to whatever is The Tick Tock
Trend and don't realize there's more
uh well that happened in my generation
people just listened to Top 40 and and
like I'm going back to the 80s now and
seeing all these cool movies and bands
that I didn't even know so I didn't dig
that deep that is part of being young
um anyway uh there are never more than
five popular songs at a time in the
school parking lot
really sucks audibly I'm not complaining
and I'm not bullied or bitter just
annoyed I listen to new music but a lot
of what makes me go wow is old
uh last year I guarantee you there's
some sick ass bands out there
it's just trying to find him his heart
uh last year in history we were learning
about the Dark Ages and I kept thinking
about how it was better before the Dark
Ages but during the Dark Ages did
someone say people always think things
were better in their day stop
complaining
uh because they are trying to make
people feel bad for not being happy with
the way things are
uh just some morning thoughts bill I
think it's fine to complain about things
as long as you check your generational
ego once in a while which you do very
often
so complain away
I think a lot of old people complaining
is uh
uh everything was better
when you were young like when people oh
my God the 80s were amazing it was just
like like were they
I mean depends on where you were
like if you were young living in the
suburbs and you were away from the crack
epidemic and you were away from uh
you know the president at the time
deregulating everything and basically
handing the keys over to these this
greed that we have now not saying he's
fully responsible but like it really set
in motion
this elimination of the uh the middle
class and not respecting unions and [__]
like that
um but there was also you know
oh here's one that [__]
took out a lot of people where I was was
cocaine
cocaine the big lie and all of that [__]
but then there was you know every time
there's good stuff and there there is
bad stuff but uh
yeah well at least what I would say to
you considering you're saying it's okay
for me to complain away don't listen to
these [__] people from my generation
that say you know nobody complained when
we were growing up you know parents were
like I'll give you something to complain
about they did and we still complained
we bitched all the time just as much as
you guys do or whatever you know believe
me
if if all of this technology existed we
would have been walking around staring
at our [__] phones too
um all right song I hate
Here We Go song I hate
um
what is this for top of the morning
Billy oh so this is something I was
saying like if there is there like a uh
like a song out there that everybody
loves and for the life of you you can't
figure out why people love it but so
many people love it you know it's got to
be you
right for me it was Bohemian Rhapsody
I'm just not into that song I [__] I
[__] hate that song I love that band
I [__] hate that song
all right but that could just be one of
those things like I Love Led Zeppelin
but if Stairway to Heaven comes on I
turn it off it might be it's just been
overplayed I don't know what but people
lose their [__] mind when that song
comes on so that started this topic
so song I hate top of the morning to you
Billy I 100 agree on your take on
Bohemian Rhapsody the song
the song that does my head in
uh is
Mr Brightside by The Killers
uh I'm not familiar with I wish I
listened to the killers more because I
downloaded one of their albums and I
loved the music and I think the guy the
lead singer's [__] voice is
incredible
so this must be a huge hit for some
reason it's a bit of an Anthem here in
the UK
and people lose their minds when it
comes on
it came out around maybe that's
something it has to do with people like
you and you're like me something about
just saying a large group of people
enjoy something makes you [__] just
automatically maybe you're contrarian
you're like yeah [__] this Mr Brightside
song
um it came out around the same time I
started at University and every time
that [__] guitar riff starts every
[__] and their uncle
it's just a funny expression every [__]
in their Uncle would go crazy for it and
I never understood why 20 years on and
the reaction is still the same
people go insane for one of the most
average songs ever jog on hope the film
uh hope the family are well and go [__]
yourself no there's a lot of songs like
um
what was what was that song uh when I
was really feeling old and I don't even
know who wrote this song this is the
story of a girl who cried a river and
drowned the whole world like women just
[__] lost their [__] when that song
came on I'm not I don't even think
that's a bad song but that was like one
of those ones where I was just like wow
this is just connecting with young
people
in a way that I am not feeling I am like
that was the first time I was like wow I
am [__] old because I you know I lied
to myself going like I'm not gonna be
one of these old people that doesn't
know about young people music I don't
understand why people just listen to
[__] so you know you know I actually
said that and this is the latest
playlist I made for when I'm at the gym
all right
um I Wanna Rock Twisted Sister
Wanted Dead or Alive Bon Jovi
don't tell me you love me Night Ranger
Sister Christian Night Ranger shake me
Cinderella somebody save me Cinderella
this is the [__] that he listened to in
high school ain't happening to me man
you know what it happens and it's
[__] great
um
anyway
plowing ahead uh uh there's a here's
another one here hated song Billy Joel
hi Bill long time fan thanks for the
laugh Billy Joel who by the way you got
to see that guy live
I saw him as Sofi Stadium I know I've
said this but just in case people missed
the podcast with Stevie Nicks opening up
I mean Stevie Nicks was was enough
she's so [__] she was [__] amazing
and then he came out and just like the
way he just was so relaxed
it would in front with all of those
people man like it was it was as a
performer watching him he was amazing so
anyway and now that I've complimented
him now he's going to get some [__] from
a listener all right Billy Joel is
obviously an extremely popular artist
some of his stuff is good some of it is
just okay but a few songs are absolute
dumpster fire garbage
the worst offender in my opinion is
Uptown Girl
oh okay I would have gone with We Didn't
Start the Fire because that just sounds
like a baby boomer not taking
responsibility like what about this what
about that uh that song is an ear raping
piece of drivel that needs to be locked
away in musical
solitary confinement and never see the
light of day again
I think some of these guys like Billy
Joel gets it a lot because the guy's all
over the [__] radio so uh I never
understood why Joel sings this song in a
nasally affected accent that isn't
present
on any of his other songs does he
Uptown Girl I guess yeah he does
I always thought he was trying to do
like a Motown thing on that
like I said what do I know I go into
into [__]
Guitar Center I'm like I want the same
high hatch that Stuart Copeland had uh
and then I still suck him um he sounds
like he gave a [__] to a can of
helium and is singing while holding his
nose Jesus whenever I'm in a room full
of people and this song comes on I want
to leave immediately in all fairness I
hate this song because I worked at the
Trader Joe's in Coolidge Corner
Brookline One Summer I'm a bu grad and
this song was in constant rotation
yeah I think it's like uh a job you
didn't like and that song reminds you of
it tell me Bill am I crazy is this not a
terrible piece of audio crap I will tell
you this I didn't get that song
when I first heard it
because he's talking about how you know
he's in love with this chick that's way
classier than him and he was sort of
painting himself as a bad boy and I was
looking at it going like what is you're
a nice little Jewish kid that plays
piano
like you're not in a gang what's going
on right I didn't understand that song
Until years later when his drinking got
out of control he started driving his
car through the front of people's
[__] houses and then I was like ah
there it is that he was trying I think
this was Billy trying to let people know
that the drinking was getting a little
out of control
and this chick's way out of her League
maybe he was trying to warn her
I don't know what but that that song
when I first heard it I was like uh you
you are an uptown guy you're at least
Midtown
you don't you come off as a nice guy
thoughtful you know interesting
introspective whatever that [__] word
is I didn't get it I think that song
you know my interpretation of that song
was maybe this is when Billy's drinking
was starting he was starting to kind of
lose
control of it
maybe or maybe he was just sitting there
going like
I am just some little fella playing a
piano what is this nine foot gorgeous
woman doing with me maybe I don't know
what it was
the self-loathing that makes him a great
artist maybe that that's what's coming
out I don't know but I will tell you
this I do not want to listen to a bunch
of people in Trader Joe's singing that
song I can definitely bond with you
um on that one
should I Throw Another Log on the Fire
and think of another [__] song
that drives me up the wall
um
well I've already talked about all that
Meatloaf [__]
you know something they there was there
was a couple of bands out there
where they really
could have been like
a completely different band but for
whatever reason
like their lead singer had too much
musical theater in them
you know oh I'll give you one
I'm not throwing anybody under the bus
but like I remember
when David Lee Roth went solo
and he gradually
became almost like this Lounge Act
and I was like what the [__] is he doing
if you really go back and listen to All
of Van Halen when he was in it it was
always there
but it was this integral part that
actually kind of
made the rest it balanced out the band
but it on it on its own
it it just wasn't something that I was
necessarily into
I still love him and he's still one of
my favorite front men of all time but
like
when he was just a Gigolo and everywhere
I was like what the [__] is he doing
this like this guy was the front man of
the best [__] rock band
like why is he doing this [__] and then
all of a sudden you go back to listen to
Van Halen won that little breakdown
or those those silly little songs
or big bad Bill is Sweet William now he
always had that sort of like
element
and it was just amazing when that got
extracted out of Van Halen and was just
it was sort of like ramped up
how different his whole vibe became
um
I don't know I gotta I gotta give you I
Gotta Give what's what's a [__]
this is like back in the day when you
were going to a record store and like
the whole week you would be thinking of
all of these [__] albums you wanted
to buy
and then you would walk into the record
store
after working you know your 40 45 hours
a week and you would just draw a blank
like what the [__] did I want to buy
I also think that was the genius of AC
DC's name
The Genius of of naming your band
a letter a is that you were at the you
were you were at the the first [__]
the albums was right there AC DC
Aerosmith Abba
all huge pants
and I think the worst what do you think
is worse
name in your band you know
I know White Snake Still did all right x
y and z are tough those are always
really skinny bins
um or like lost in like the shuffle
M's ends
I still think they did all right I don't
know what what is a [__] I'm gonna
give you guys one God damn it I'm gonna
sit here and think of something what is
a [__] song
that comes oh Jesus
oh no I can't do this I can't do this
because Neil will get mad at me but she
has someone
that she listens to
and I for the life of me
I just don't get it
I'm not doing this I'm not doing this
because you know what's gonna happen to
me I'm gonna run into one of these
people and then it's going to be [__]
super awkward I don't want to do that
but oh my God
it's like I just I don't [__]
[Applause]
I'm talking like fans crying
when they watch this person on stage and
I'm just sitting there going like what
in the [__]
am I watching
um but they're all younger so maybe
that's what it is I don't know what
This Is A Dangerous Game
you know
maybe I should stop playing this because
I'm gonna end up [__] running into
somebody and then it's just gonna be a
bad thing
I thought you liked my music I heard
what you said in the podcast you know
um
all right here's one for you who you on
the fence with
what's a band where you're kind of like
you know
you're not an album guy you're just like
the singles
you know what Billy Joel
but Billy Joel's written so many [__]
hits like I don't think he could miss
with one of his albums right I don't
[__] know
all right listen I got enough problems I
could truck drivers rear end of me I
don't need this [__] all right whatever
you guys want to keep going with this
I gotta pick something else
um all right and with that that's the
podcast for this week uh next time I
talk to you I will be in uh the other
side of the world uh thank you to
everybody in Abu Dhabi that got tickets
I hope I don't [__] piss you off
thanking everybody else Prague Stockholm
Berlin
um Budapest
last time I was there I was just like I
should have made a specialty of these
[__] people are amazing so I'm really
looking forward to all of that
um
and I'm going over there with uh
uh Bianca Bianca Christoval and Nate
Craig it's going to be [__] awesome
um wire to wire it's just gonna be a
killer show so if you're over there I
hope you got your tickets because it's
going to be a great show all right
that's it I'll talk to you later